is your morning habit slowly poisoning
you
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be chatting about the six
scariest side effects of coffee but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
buildbar so it is springtime around here
so we did a major clear out of the
pantry this weekend basically to make
room for more build bars but if you have
not tried my favorite bar yet you're
welcome i don't know i find most protein
bars on the market are like super chalky
and gritty but build bars have a texture
kind of like a nugget or like a thick
marshmallow and it's coated in actual
chocolate hello what are we doing today
folks
[Music]
decisions decisions
let's go for like
the classic coconut almond this is one
of my favorites
and i didn't know that i liked coconut
that much until i had this bar so
[Music]
combo
[Music]
this one's got 18 grams of protein
and it's a lower sugar bar so if you
want to build it into like a hunger
crushing combo i love to pair it with
oatmeal or toast or fruit so many great
options so if you want to check out belt
bars for yourself check out my link in
the description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
okay and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
as we will be discussing weight loss and
metabolism boosting hacks and if you are
not already subscribed hit that sub
button and don't forget to follow me
over on tick tock and instagram abby's
kitchen and let's kick things off by
discussing my best friend of me caffeine
love it hate it need it or not there's a
lot to unpack so caffeine is a natural
stimulant that eighty percent of the
world's population consume via
substances like coffee tea energy drinks
soft drinks and chocolate most of us
drink coffee to feel more awake
energized and alert some of us don't
even feel like ourselves without a hit
[Music]
and this is because caffeine works by
blocking the neurotransmitter adenosine
which is responsible for making you feel
tired while also stimulating our
energizing neurotransmitters adrenaline
dopamine and norepinephrine love me some
neurotransmitter stimulation in the am
now considering the frequency of
consumption it is no surprise that
caffeine is one of the most
researched edible substances on the
planet with most authorities suggesting
that it's safe to consume up to 400
milligrams of caffeine a day which is
equivalent to about four cups of coffee
why the cap well
like all substances it is possible to
get too much of a good thing and in
wellness culture there's a lot of
chatter about coffee being toxic
poisonous or ultimately bad for your
health so today we are going to break
down some of those claims and deliver
the facts after i get in a little sip
obviously
let's go claim number one
coffee causes anxiety disorders whoa
that'll do it we've all done it right
like that one extra cup of liquid gold
and we are on our ass unable to type a
coherent email because our hands don't
stop shaking it's not a good feeling but
i mean
that's kind of what caffeine does
caffeine is a stimulant so it can
increase blood pressure and heart rate
and for a lot of us those physical
sensations can be interpreted by the
mind as like holy footballs something is
wrong and this is especially true among
folks who are coughing newbies or who
are genetically more sensitive to
caffeine so caffeine sensitivity
basically refers to how efficiently your
body specifically your liver is able to
metabolize caffeine and clear it from
your system so for example fast
metabolizers can perhaps tolerate
several cups of coffee a day or even
have coffee like an hour before bed and
have no apparent trouble sleeping while
slow metabolizers need to cut themselves
off really early to get a good night's
rest we also need to consider someone's
experience with caffeine so one theory
is that folks who've made caffeine part
of their daily ritual develop more
adenosine receptors in the brain which
then binds the caffeine and reduce its
kind of buzzy effect over time and while
research suggests that folks with
pre-existing social anxiety panic
disorder or anxiety disorders are at a
higher risk of feeling the
anxiety-inducing effects of caffeine
it's very important to note that
caffeine itself
doesn't create an anxiety disorder some
folks in the research don't actually see
an increase in anxiety or perceived
stress at all so this is very much a
individualized thing i have personally
cut out caffeine at different points in
my life to see if it reduces my anxiety
and between you and i
it just kind of makes me a less happy
human being so not unlike with any
substance this is where we may have to
weigh out the benefits and the risk on
an individual level so bottom line your
personal experience with coffee
triggering anxiety will likely depend on
genetically determined metabolism your
tolerance and consumption habits when in
the day you consume it and your baseline
anxiety levels so experiment to
determine what works best for you claim
number two
decaf coffee contains carcinogens okay
so maybe caffeine in you don't play nice
in the sandbox so you want to switch to
decaf now there are three common methods
by which caffeine is removed from the
coffee bean number one the swiss water
process which uses only water to
dissolve the caffeine two the co2 method
which uses compressed co2 and three the
most common solvent method which uses
synthetic chemicals like ethyl acetate
and methylene chloride now when people
harp on decaf it's because of the
chemical solvents like methylene
chloride used in most brews now what we
know is that inhaling about 200 parts
per million of methylene chloride can
temporarily slow down the central
nervous system which depending on the
level of exposure could potentially
cause things like lightheadedness
coughing or even shortness of breath
however the fda has approved use of
methylene chloride in caffeine
extraction processes because the final
product contains only trace amounts with
no more than 10 parts per million so
that is point zero zero one percent now
research suggests that this amount is
far too minuscule to have any negative
effects on health and most decaf coffees
on the market today contain levels that
are even a hundred times lower than this
or as little as one part per million
because basically the roasting process
effectively can reduce those residues
it's also worth noting that there's a
huge difference between taking a whiff
of like your cup of decaf and inhaling
straight up methylene chloride via like
paint thinner for example but of course
if you're still concerned and love your
decaf you can always purchase products
that use the water method instead there
isn't any regulation requiring decaf
processes to be identified on food
labels so you can either look at this
information on a brand's website or
choose an organic product where chemical
solvents are not used claim number three
coffee contains toxic mold a lot of
influencers insist that coffee contains
mycotoxins from molds grown on coffee
beans if improperly stored and that some
of these toxins can have carcinogenic
properties so researchers found small
amounts of these microtoxins in tested
coffee beans but their levels are
consistently far below the safe amount
for human consumption keep in mind that
we are exposed to mycotoxins basically
every single day in a wide range of
foods so much so that virtually
everyone's blood will test positive for
them and it's even often found in
obviously healthy foods like human
breast milk so considering that one
study found that consuming your full
four cups of coffee per day provided
only two percent of the toxin exposure
deemed safe it's likely a non-issue for
most decaf will have slightly higher
amounts but it's still well below the
tolerable level now honestly the topic
of mold injury is a huge one but just
know that most claims associated with
this wellness culture concern rbs which
brings me to claim number four
coffee increases cortisol levels people
love to talk about cortisol without
actually knowing much about what it is
but in short cortisol is a stress
hormone that's primarily involved in the
body's stress response which makes it
seem very very bad but it's actually
also important for positive bodily
processes like reducing inflammation
supporting nutrient metabolism and
helping to control blood sugar levels so
we need cortisol and it's natural for
our levels to be kind of higher in the
morning and lower when we go to bed at
night but prolonged periods of elevated
levels throughout the day can cause
things like headaches weight gain
insomnia osteoporosis immune suppression
and more so a lot of influencers insist
that you should not drink coffee on an
empty stomach in the morning because it
raises your cortisol levels even higher
at a point in the day when it's
naturally kind of at its highest point
and this is theoretically true but
realistically
not actually a really big deal some
studies suggest that caffeine can
increase cortisol levels both at rest
and during periods of stress but other
research has found no increase in
cortisol levels at all and this
individual variation likely has to do
with one's sensitivity to stress anxiety
high blood pressure and most importantly
their tolerance to caffeine here's the
really important piece of information
that wellness influencers don't tell you
any effect of caffeine on your cortisol
levels seems to diminish with regular
caffeine consumption in other words if
you drink coffee regularly within an
hour of waking up
like most human freaking beings do your
body adapts to this habit it learns nope
like this is not a bear coming to eat me
that's the thing about bear attacks they
come when you least expect it it's just
the usual double double in a bagel and
this significantly bloods the transient
effects on cortisol and that's a really
important other key word here transient
i appreciate that if you have a million
things working against you and your
anxiety disorder then it absolutely is
worth taking all of these little steps
to reduce stress and abnormal cortisol
levels in the day but for most people
the minute transient effects of a daily
cup of coffee on cortisol levels are
unlikely to cause long-term harm as for
the empty stomach concern i would say
theoretically it makes sense to have
some food with your coffee if you do
experience ill effects though we don't
necessarily have actual evidence that
would make a really big deal or
difference so i say you know experiment
to see what feels best for you i know
that i don't physically feel good if i
have coffee on an empty stomach so i
will always pair it with some kind of
milk and a latte and usually either
breakfast or a snack claim number five
it increases insulin and blood sugars so
speaking of drinking coffee on an empty
stomach
let's talk about that research on blood
sugar now with so much fear around
insulin a lot of influencers are
swearing that drinking your black coffee
in the morning raises your blood sugars
and your insulin levels now we do have
some research that folks with type 2
diabetes tend to see a bump in blood
sugar and insulin levels after caffeine
consumption which may be related to
genetics and caffeine metabolism and
while one study on healthy individuals
did find higher fasting insulin levels
in folks drinking a big old pot of
coffee the authors noted that they did
give these guys a whopping 13 cups of
coffee straight out the gates which
let's be real that could have increased
stress levels to cause the ill effects
now it seems that a tolerance to the
insulin increasing effect of caffeine
occurs over time which again would
explain why review of the literature
found that regular moderate consumption
of coffee consistently seems to reduce
the risk of pre-diabetes and type 2
diabetes one of the studies even found
that you could reduce your risk by 11
by increasing your coffee consumption so
yes this is a very complicated area of
research and like most nutrition
research is highly individualized but it
seems like if you're a regular coffee
drinker consuming moderate amounts of
coffee and you have a healthy pancreas
your habit is not going to cause
abnormal blood sugar levels and if you
have diabetes it's important to take
note of how your morning coffee is
affecting your levels and of course
switch to decaf if it's a consistent
problem and finally let's talk claim
number six
that caffeine increases metabolism and
encourages weight loss i know you've
been waiting since the start for this
one so here it is there's always been a
lot of buzz about caffeine's fat burning
and metabolism boosting effects is there
any truth to this well
yes and no there is some research that
caffeine may increase fat burning by up
to 13
and boost metabolic rate by 11
now caffeine has also been shown to
increase heat production in the body
otherwise known as thermogenesis which
raises body temperature and increases
energy expenditure and while those all
seem like really big exciting numbers to
somebody who wants to lose weight and
who likes their coffee you'd likely have
to consume an unhealthy amount of
caffeine to see any kind of measurable
effect on top of your caloric deficit so
for example
one study found that caffeine doses of
4.5 milligrams per pound of body weight
increased metabolism by up to 13 percent
so for someone who weighs 150 pounds
this is equal to
675 milligrams of caffeine or
seven cups of coffee well beyond the
four cup a day max recommendation
and even if you could tolerate this
amount without undue harm or side
effects it wouldn't necessarily
translate to less food consumed or
weight lost on the scale and this is
where things get messy as
in the research so with appetite one
study found that drinking coffee shortly
before a meal slightly decreased caloric
intake since caffeine seems to slightly
reduce the hunger hormone ghrelin
however these appetite suppressing
effects don't appear to be sustained
like three to four hours after you drink
the coffee leading folks to likely just
make up for the mist calories later on
then on the flip side other research
found no differences in calorie intake
when drinking coffee before a meal so
apparently the impact on hunger hormones
isn't necessarily consistent or strong
as for the numbers on the scale some
evidence suggests that caffeine intake
is associated with a 17 to 28 increase
in weight loss while another study
determined that the weight loss from
caffeine intake was not statistically
significant at all and that caffeine
drinkers were only about one pound
lighter than those who did not drink
caffeine it's important to note that all
of these pathetically minuscule
potential impacts on weight loss are
confounded by how and what you take in
your coffee in other words if you're
replacing a coke with black coffee then
yeah you're going to cut 150 calories
per drink and over time you'll
potentially lose weight but if you're
adding a double double to your day
morning noon and night thinking it's
gonna magically burn fat off your body
you're probably going to be disappointed
and to take this even further if your
coffee habit is interfering with your
sleep it may actually contribute to
weight gain and this is because unlike
the poor mixed research linking caffeine
used to lower body weight sleep research
has consistently correlated sleep
deprivation with increased appetite
weight and metabolic disturbances so as
usual no one finding and nutrition
research can be acted on in isolation we
really need to see the forest from the
trees so in conclusion coffee is not a
magical weight loss drug but it's also
not the poison that so many wellness
influencers make it out to be there's
also a lot of potential benefits to
coffee like improving gut health
exercise performance and cognition while
reducing the risk of alzheimer's
parkinson's and even depression if you
don't need coffee in the morning great
but don't belittle us addicts for our
habit the reason i don't review other
people's coffee orders here on abby's
kitchen is that i kind of see coffee or
tea or whatever your preference is as
like a non-denominational ritual that
really should just not be messed with
for a lot of us
coffee sets the tone for the day and
only you can determine if that's good or
a not so good habit for you so unless
someone's morning cup comes with a side
of pseudoscience i'm gonna just
walk on by now please excuse me i need a
little top up here and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today
thanks again to billbar for sponsoring
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if there are other ingredients or
foods you want to see me review like
this subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]